oh yeah
i've been making this drink sound so
attractive and desirable for all these
years do you recognize me
i'm the kool-aid man oh
yeah
so i've had several people say it's hard
to picture that that voice is actually
coming
from you the human being oh yeah
they like the voice because they don't
know who i am
when i first auditioned i think they
wanted to get the flavor of the kool-aid
man that was already on the air oh yeah
when i came in instead of making it oh
oh i wanted to go down oh
oh oh
so he's gonna have a big deep voice so i
just thought like this guy wants to be
here oh yeah
cool and i tried to make the voice
you know just kind of roll around
gutterly in my throat oh yeah
i can remember those sessions after
three hours of them just saying okay do
it again do it again do it again try it
again how about lower more energy more
this more very wide bigger bigger bigger
louder louder i'd be saying like what am
i not doing that you're not getting but
you're telling me to use a lot of high
energy like david lee roth i said the
two don't mix david lee roth's going oh
yeah doesn't mix with barry white going
oh yeah so you have to find a happy
balance oh yeah
bottoms up
hmm